in fahrtrichtung allem einig sie dass
man sie wenn sie fit ihre und nicht nur
apps machen werden nur noch kultur
machen
man tut jeder baum oder warum nur wird
man als parameter solcher pflanzen
richtig der charakter von der familie
malente eu fast mal was ein blick hört
könnte
ich hab's nacht hinblick und schlafen
das mit sorge macht und was ich alles
irgendwie nicht richtig gemacht haben in
der vergangenheit sind sich beide
überzeugt dass es fehler genügt hat
woods nach nicht einfach ruhig schlafen
gehen sie irgendwie so viel gemacht
hätten
[Applaus]
sojaernte im westen brasiliens
bundesstaat mato grosso vor 30 jahren
bildnis herrschte regiert jetzt die
industrielle landwirtschaft
der neue boom hat die stadt lukas loriot
werde zu einer der reichsten städte
brasiliens gemacht gegründet wurde die
stadt vor knapp 40 jahren von schweizer
auswanderern in der savanne brasiliens
wollten sie die tugenden ihrer heimat
durchsetzen
gute schulen und gemeinschaftliches
arbeiten
ihr traum hat sich auf eine ganz andere
weise erfüllt statt vielfalt regiert die
monokultur wahlkampf der familie huber
für eine gerechtere welt vergebens
dieser frage gehen wir in diesem film
nach
[Musik]
luis huber war 13 als er mit seinem
vater in die wildnis zog und hier zum
pionier wurde
er besucht einen historischen ort anton
huber gründete mit anderen siedlern
zusammen eine genossenschaft vor 30
jahren erstellten sie das erste
getreidesilo in der gegend
der vater ist ende 2015 gestorben in
seinem getreidesilo werden jährlich noch
immer 60.000 tonnen soja gereinigt und
getrocknet
wie aber wurde eine schweizer
bauernfamilie im wilden westen
brasiliens zu städte gründer klaus huber
der onkel von louis hat die ganze
geschichte von anfang an mitgemacht so
schön gebaut und bietet der sonderklasse
und hat diese werbung ist so richtig
gespürt und ich brauche das auch
magische christen moment so mal so dick
wie im beruf zwecke 1951 wanderten die
hubers mit neun kindern aus dem
luzernischen co2 nach brasilien aus
klaus war zehn als die hubers mit dem
schiff im hafen von santos ankamen
in der schweiz gab der bahnhof nicht
genügend her um allen kindern eine
ausbildung zu ermöglichen
heute leitet klaus huber institut für
alternativmedizin und umwelterziehung am
rande von lukas studio werde hier
kultivierte die heilenden kräuter die in
der natur kaum noch zu finden sind
klaus lebt als einziger der geschwister
noch in lukas trio werde
hier hütet er die erinnerung an die
suche der familie huber nach einem
besseren leben
20 jahre nach der auswanderung hatten
die who ihren traum vom eigenen land
immer noch nicht verwirklicht wie andere
pächter und kleinbauern waren sie bei
den banken verschuldet
ende der 70er jahre gab die regierung
das riesige buschmann den westen
brasiliens zum anbau frei hier bekamen
die hubers mit 50 weiteren interessenten
land um eine landwirtschaftliche kolonie
aufzubauen zweieinhalb mal so groß wie
der kanton luzern
[Musik]
die anfänge waren beschwerlich ohne
strom mit viel staub und mücken die
hubers lebt nicht selten wuschen sich in
fluss sie schlossen die siedler in einer
genossenschaft zusammen gründeten
schulen auf druck der regierung
schlossen sich dem projekt 200 landlose
bauern familien aus dem süden brasiliens
an land war und das ist die größte
distanz des schuhs gab wo denn und riesa
für die tat während ich also so eine art
gemeinschaftszentrum wo dann die
digitalisierte nach basierend treffen
und der schuh
grünen könnte der jetzige und er ist
graphen und organisieren
klaus huber und seine damalige frau
bauten die schulen auf die einsatz
führte zu konflikten mit beamten der
regierung sie einfach und gemeinde
momentan politisch statik sie im sinn
asvg dem event gemacht hat und das ist
einfach sie dementsprechend bringen wenn
man in der gut die erzieher hatte
motiviert wenn man eine gute schule hat
denn funktioniert alles sah man ihn nach
dem schulsystem und weil deine frage
teilen aber dumm angemacht und hatte
eine gemeinschaftlich organisiert wurde
sind ein großer druck muss spüren ich
lieber nichts kann alles verzeihen
soja das war die goldene verheißung im
weiten und wilden westen brasiliens wo
die neue kornkammer der welt entstehen
sollte brach ein unbarmherziger kampf um
das land aus mit fäusten und kugeln
ausgetragen wurde
er hat bis heute seine dramatischen
spielen hinterlassen
ein besuch bei luis huber und seiner
frau 40 kilometer außerhalb von lukas
studio werde hier züchten sie geflügel
und pflanzen bäume pflanzt hand mit der
natur kommt doch die wildnis zurück da
vorne ist es risiken wie den usa wo mit
dem mit dem quer und dann haben wir
chancen aber nicht zum verleih
zivilisierten deshalb darf nicht machen
denn ist denn unseren den baum täter
orangenbaum berichtete staub leber habe
nur noch mal flüchtet und dränge da aber
inzwischen mit einer vielfältigen
landwirtschaft nimmt louis eine
ursprüngliche idee seines vaters wieder
auf und das ist die idee von der
gesellschaft gesetzt wo anfangen
und wieso ist alles ganz anders geworden
wie ein blick zum nachbarn zeigt das hat
er fast in europa league wo einfach
alles versichern welle h lied wurde
überhaupt nicht einmal hat er dörfer
land sitzen wenn sie sind aufgestellt
von der regierung und die hände abhacken
der vater kein familienvater hat einfach
mehr auf die richtige welle und hat als
aufmacht hat luis huber keine angst über
diese zeit zu sprechen als bewaffnete
schergen seinen vater bedrohten gemacht
die jetzt erzähle dass ich jetzt in der
tatsache dass ein felix und in das steht
sogar die betätigen will im magdeburger
wer wo was macht hat die pioniere aus
der schweiz wehrten sich gegen den
landraub und verteidigten ihre
heimatlichen ideale wie vater hat sich
geweigert so zum gegenstand meter auf
erneut dass ich nicht richtig da muss
wieder ran an die familie damit nicht
nur ein großer baustart und und
sächlichen verschwinden das ist die
tiefsee
seine geschwister leben und arbeiten in
der schweiz
deshalb ist luis huber in brasilien
geblieben schöne da ich erst mal bis
nach machen
das ist nur machbar dass man irgendwie
so ein staudamm karriere produzieren und
dass man irgendwie noch ein bis zwei
stunden machen das ist nun möglich
das ist irgendwie euroshop nach
mit steuererleichterungen und krediten
fördert die brasilianische regierung den
großgrundbesitz nur wenigen bescherte
die soja märchenhaften reichtum von den
200 landlosen bauern aus dem süden die
mit den hubers nachwuchs studio werte
gekommen waren sind 190 wieder
weggezogen in rom anziehen ist geblieben
auf 500 hektar land baut der so jahren
in der stadt führt er ein warenhaus ich
kam mit meiner familie 1982 ihr an am 31
bei lukas do rio verde existierten es
gab nichts und du weißt was das bedeutet
nichts von gar nichts
damals wurde einer ihrer nachbarn von
einem schlangenbiss getötet heute gibt
es in lukas ein spital und zwei
universitäten an die pioniere aus der
schweiz erinnert sich romans ihn gerne
zur familie huber gehörten der androhung
der die große genossenschaft aufbaute
klaus huber und seine damalige frau
bettina paetsch war die bildung das
wichtigste das gefiel ihr das war ihr
thema
elisabeth kurmann kam in brasilien zur
welt sie begleitete ihren damaligen mann
klaus huber mit vier kindern in die
wildnis
diese kilometer vor der ampel
ich damals nach langer zeit besucht
elisabeth kurmann eine der schulen
wieder die sie gegründet hat ihren
schulen gab sie damals die namen von
dichtern gegen den widerstand der
lokalen machthaber die lieber den namen
eines politikers gesehen hätten
mit den schulen sie hielten sich immer
mehr familien in der gegend an
damit begann du kannst du dir werde zu
wachsen aber der schulverwaltung findet
keine erinnerungen an die zeit als
elisabeth ihre in einem holzschuppen
portugiesisch unterrichtet überhaupt
sind in der reichen soja stadt die
erinnerungen an die schweizer
verschwunden
das alles tut mir nicht gut
es sind so viele erinnerungen hochkommen
die drohungen haben dazu geführt dass
man sich immer mehr zurückzog
ich habe immer noch angst zu sprechen
ist das zu glauben aber ich werde
sprechen
wir waren zeugung wie funktionäre die
landverteilung manipulierten und arme
siedler vertrieben
wir besuchten die schulen im ganzen
inland aller 30 kilometer gab es eine
kleine schule nicht so schön wie hier
sondern eine hütte und damit hatten wir
zugang zu den eltern
und so erfuhren wir all diese sachen es
waren kleine landwirte die verstreut
lebten und ihre eigenen rechte nicht
kann und wir begannen diese leute
aufzuklären
und damit machen wir uns unbeliebt
pistoleros drohten ihr haus anzuzünden
ihre familie wurde mit dem tod bedroht
unterwegs mit dem auto parkte sie nicht
anzuhalten
ja es gab drohungen ich hatte große
angst und wenn jemand nachts an der
straße standort mitfahren wollte und die
ganzen anstrengungen in der wildnis eine
bessere welt zu schaffen
die realität hat uns besiegt die
realität dieser fächer in der realität
waren sie die mehrheit
vielleicht wenn unsere gruppe etwas
größer gewesen wäre
aber wir waren träume naiver träumer
[Musik]
das ist die realität die sich
durchgesetzt hat eine hochproduktive
landwirtschaft der es den beruf des
bauern kaum noch gibt
die setzlinge werden im genlabor
entworfen
die chemiekonzerne bestimmen was gut ist
für den boden und was nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vor 30 jahren träumten die hubers von
etwas ganz anderem ihr projekt sah vor
dass jeder kleinbauer einen teil seines
waldes schützt und dazu eigenes obst und
eigenes gemüse pflanzt der große traum
erzählt renate aufgelöst was mitteilten
dass mit david dem réver alles und das
ist sowohl als die reine luft gestemmt
und 523 an die darauf hofften dass sie
die linie
hauptgast erodiert macht den dom er
heute noch mit dem traktor als unterhält
als sie nach paar meter messen kann ab
die anbauschlacht in der savanne wurde
auch von der weltbank und großen
internationalen unternehmen gefördert
wenn ich die ganze produktion für monate
lange frist verwiesen heil transmitter
verbundes 50 tepco gericht wo diese
nicht mit abstand der fall ist hat
vergifteten jetzt finden die
heilpflanzen der savanne klaus hubers
instituts immer mehr interesse der
schüler und der schule zeigen dass man
meister schied und warum hast du mir
alles kaputt macht was würdige heimrecht
in der natur ihnen ist wenn das nur das
wichtig ist
[Musik]
erntezeit die lukas trio werbe jede
trockene stunde wird ausgenutzt
feuchtigkeit verminderten wert der ware
welche die stadt reich gemacht hat
die stadt ist zu einem mächtigen zentrum
der agrarindustrie geworden
ihre bewohner leben eng zusammen mit den
vor und nachteilen des fortschritts
[Musik]
zu hause erinnern sich elizabeth und ihr
sohn bruno an die anfangszeiten als
bewaffnete schergen drohten die haus
anzuzünden
weil sich die eltern für die rechte der
kleinen bauern wirken wenn das fahrrad
club damals war wohl nur sechs jahre alt
später zog die familie vorübergehend in
die schweiz wo nur eine lehre machte es
ist schon
ich bewundere ich weiß aber auch bruno
setzt die familientradition fort er
zieht weiter
die zukunft ist ich fühle mich nicht
wohl aber ich finde nicht dass das
statische und ich wollte wurde misst ins
kind aufwachsen können wir nur weil du
keine chance
schön blühen sie und jetzt wenn man da
zu tragen sieht ist schade dass blum mit
monokulturen sind natürlich auch andere
schwierigkeit wie gift wo man jetzt auch
im wasserrinne hält oder man weiß
eigentlich nicht so mit klink
brunos vater klaus huber ist im reinen
mit sich und der welt die er mit
geschaffen hat mit dem druck und den wie
es mit dem trost dass man seit vielen
verbänden sache jetzt passierte mir das
erklärt dieser traum ist abgehandelt
wurde vielleicht euro fest
eigentlich aber das ist sehr viel
passiert wenn wir das 3
mittlerweile während sich die kinder in
den schulen die er gegründet hat wenn
wieder ein stück wald abgeholzt wird
das sind wie wichtig ist dass ich sie da
die bürger demnach mache das sind
natürlich ganz zerstört und manchmal
dauert es einfach ein bisschen länger
bis der boden reif ist für eine bessere
sein
[Musik]